if you turn the TV all anyone's talking
about is the polar vortex yes that is
that this guy's like yeah pull the
vortex getting it done
yeah it's crazy that's the big story
Midwest polar vortex but here in Los
Angeles we have something just as bad
moderate rain [ __ ] pots and prayers to
LA Johnson that way you grew up in the
Midwest I grew up in the East Coast it
rained all the time here in LA when it
rains all the traffic lights stopped
working people get out of their cars and
just start running around like idiots
it's madness yes like for like about a
half an hour Twitter was nothing but
thunder the gods are angry 70% of the
country right now is a still covered by
very very cold temperatures yeah yeah
miserable to go outside for a lot of
people in America which has inspired the
Southern California tourist bureau to
put out this ad
polar vortex or solar vortex
it's your choice America Southern
California visit us anytime
just don't move here jessica's bad
enough without your car also if we get
wildfires and mudslides and droughts and
earthquakes and block after block of
homeless tents and an average class size
of 37 students full disclosure if you
have a cat you're gonna lose it the
coyote and all the way downtown we're
also the homes of savage murderers that
aging porn stars can linger at ATM
machines Southern California three days
I love that motto three days time you'll
have a good time and then get out of
here Super Bowl anyone excited about the
Super Bowl this weekend I brought it up
to the crowd last night they didn't care
la is in the Super Bowl it well it took
a day to get the news that yeah this
town does not know that's the super team
in the Super Bowl
no it's right we got the Real Housewives
so the excitement's are we yeah you know
well you know a lot of people watch for
the halftime show right let's be honest
this is the weird story this year they
couldn't get anyone to play the Super
Bowl halftime show this year they really
did have a very hard time and then
finally they got maroon 5 yeah yeah
apparently maroon 1 through 4 said no
now you could wonder was that joke worth
it or not
thank you
thank you very much thank you that joke
got you elected to City Council head
today you know that Super Bowl ads cost
the most ever this year you know that
yeah so will ads cost five million
dollars or get this a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars per second
for a Super Bowl ad to put that in
perspective a 30-second commercial on
this show my show the Conan show costs
$200 plus I give you a ride to the
airport
that explains our sponsor Doris is going
to see your grandkid and needs a ride
yeah that's right over a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars a second
that's what it really costs so get this
this kind of makes sense in an effort to
save money a bunch of companies are
airing commercials that are only a
couple of seconds long for example
here's one have arthritis try xeljanz
maybe diarrhea
I know a lot of people are doing that in
fact here's another one better
ingredients better pizza Papa John maybe
diarrhea yeah here's another one who has
diarrhea
[Laughter]
and the best for last finally diarrhea
you